music wars television scandals movie
masterpieces and major disappointments
2015 had at all so let's look at wire
its top 5 entertainment stories for the
year 2015 number 5 we got Taylor Swift
the 25 year old pop singer brought Apple
to its knees this year by threatening
withhold her massive album in 1989 from
Apple's new streaming service Swift
actually forced the tech giant to
reconsider its policy and pay artists
royalties during its free 3 month trial
period t swift one Apple zero in a
number four if the idea of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe might actually be
stalling out a little bit the latest
Avengers movie was an uncharacteristic
stumble the studio Marvel Comics good
blockbuster movies good Joss Whedon good
yet age of Ultron was kind of a boring
formulaic mess at number three we turn
to the small screen did you kill Joffrey
Game of Thrones netted its biggest
audience ratings ever for the season 5
finale with over 8 million viewers but
all everyone was talking about was that
rape seen a few episodes back Wired's
take Game of Thrones use of rape as a
plot device was actually just lazy and
while rape scenes might seem edgy it's
really just poor writing it's been a
huger for VR so naturally comes in at
the number two spot virtual reality took
off in a big way the small outfits began
churning out their first VR films we got
our first look at one of the best
disease offerings this summer when
oculus a story studio released Henry
it's CGI VR experience why are we so
excited because it offered a glimpse at
what filmmaking could look like in the
near future and in a huge upset
unprecedented our number one store of
the year is about the federal art house
movie star wars the force awakens months
no no years of anticipation made
December eighteenth with
let's hope the Disney and Lucasfilm
efforts to resuscitate the star wars
franchise means we won't live to see the
last Star Wars movie what a way to end
the year